we all have a voice in our head  some of us are very spiritual some of us  are not but we all have this voice and  you're doing  this is wrong don't do that  the more you don't listen to that voice  the further that voice gets away from  your head some people call it the holy  spirit some people call it gossip monks  whatever whatever you call it it's there  we all have it  it's the right or wrong voice  but the more we don't listen to it the  more that voice goes away the only voice  you hear is yourself  i mean all when the only bush here is  yourself you're wrong  there's a voice that guides you through  life  but sometimes this guy in your direction  that you don't want to go  that's usually the right place to go  it's that uncomfortable place so that  voice  is always talking to me but we don't  listen to it i listen to it